you're on a trial right now you're under
yes it's essentially a trial you're
being brought up on you have to take
social media
re-education re-education from your
province is saying this is that right um
it's a it's a professional group but
they have delegated authority from the
provinces so there are regulated
professions okay and Engineers lawyers
Physicians psychologists social workers
teachers there's there's a few others
and if you're in a regulated profession
there's a professional body that governs
professional conduct to which the public
has access in case people misbehave and
so the Ontario College of psychologists
its colleges in group professional group
rather than University and it's the
Ontario College of psychologists that
have decided to pursue initially 13
charges against me they dropped seven
why they dropped those seven is a
complete mystery as is everything else
they do
you can submit a complaint to the
College of psychologists online with a
form and so what's happened at least in
part is because that's become so easy
it's become weaponized by activists so
for example if you want to cause anybody
who's in professional trouble all you
have to do is submit a complaint to the
college the college
we'll look into the complaint every
complaint and then decide whether
they'll proceed now they're not supposed
to proceed if the complaints are
vexatious or you know just troublemaking
but they've decided that me complaining
on Twitter about Trudeau for example is
uh unprofessional and a disgraced is a
disgrace to the profession which is
essentially what I've been charged with
is being a disgrace to the profession so
it's trying to hold up what they presume
is some esteem of the prev of the
profession that's the that's the theory
and some Professional Standards and you
know I would say for decades that system
actually worked pretty well because the
people who sat on it weren't
ideologically adult and the public
wasn't using it in a weaponized manner
but that's changed completely and now
every professional in Canada and I
believe that to be true is essentially
without exception unless they're on the
far left
are completely unwilling to ever utter
any opinion about anything in the
political or their professional realm
especially in relationship to medicine
and psychology so I appealed this ruling
so the ruling essentially is that
I have to take
social media retraining with a social
media expert and I'd like to make it
very clear there is no such thing as
there's no profession yes like The
Wizard of Oz like who is it going to be
is it do you know the expert no I don't
that's correct no I've got a couple of
names but I don't even know what defines
you as a social media expert and neither
does the college and they don't care you
know if someone presents themselves as a
social media expert that's good enough
my sense is that if you're a social
media expert
you have a podcast with millions of
followers and you're doing just fine on
your own and you actually don't need to
work for an idiot bureaucracy but you
know that's just me right so now not
only do I have to be re-educated by this
social media expert but I have to do it
at my own expense which you know was
neither here nor there in some sense but
for an indefinite period of time wow
until I've learned whatever the hell
lesson I'm supposed to learn and I don't
exactly know what lesson that is
by their judgment right and so so it's
all up to them so it's kind of this
vague thing that they've put you into
and they challenged you because they
they were upset at things you had said
on Twitter no well okay they also and
maybe that that maybe this can happen
today somebody submitted
the entire transcript of my last
conversation with Joe Rogan as a
complaint partly because of what I said
about climate change now I am not a fan
of climate change models which I think
are
to call them flawed is to barely scrape
the surface so do you feel like but
they're so they're challenging your
things you've said on social media right
yeah well so do you think it's a
challenge of your free speech is that
what you feel like oh I the the court
that ruled against my appeal essentially
said that it was a free speech issue
okay and they said in their opening
argument that according to the Canadian
Charter of Rights which was by the way
instantiated by Justin Trudeau's father
Pierre Trudeau and Justin's regime is in
the process of absolutely gutting it
anyways I have a right to free speech
according to that Charter but and that's
the next sentence this very low level
bureaucratic institution has the right
to abridge that essentially as they see
fit which means as far as I can tell
that I don't have the right to free
speech at all and I should make very
clear
those colleges should be intervening
when a client or a patient right or
customer depending on the regulated
profession has been mistreated in some
manner by the person they're dealing
with okay the people that levied
complaints against me first of all most
of them don't live in Canada second of
all none of them were clients of mine
third none of them knew anyone who was a
client of mine they claimed harm that I
had done harm on behalf of other people
who they also didn't know they also a
number of them also claimed to be
clients of mine in writing in the
complaint they're not no they're not
clients of mine and clients of mine
before I became politically known let's
say I practiced as a clinician for more
than 20 years and I had zero complaints
and I had zero complaints levied against
me at the University too either at
Harvard or at the University of Toronto
and the reason for that was that I
treated my students my colleagues my
co-workers and my clients well all the
time there was Zero problems but as soon
as things exploded around me politically
well the people who've weaponized the
colleges have taken that opportunity to
go after me and then the college which
is nicely Infested by radicals like
almost everything else in the west and
particularly in Canada are using this
opportunity to attempt to make my life
miserable but we'll see whose lives are
made miserable
wow
yeah do you feel do you do you almost
was there a part of you that kind of was
like excited about the car like not to
not to begin with like it's not ever
entertaining to face legal proceedings
yeah you have to be a fool generally
speaking to think that even if you're
the one loving a lawsuit you have to be
a real fool to think that it's going to
do anything but cause you a lot of grief
and misery like lawsuits are not
entertaining and I have quite a
pronounced proclivity to feel guilt and
I went through the like this has been
going on a long time off and on for
about six years but the ruling just
happened right well the Court ruling
that denied my appeal just happened okay
to go through yeah
no the next thing they have to do I
either have to go through with the
training or they have they can drag me
in front of a disciplinary board and my
next move is going to be to say
hey bring on the disciplinary board they
film those wow I will put that on
YouTube
so if they want to make the case that
for example my objections to the trans
surgical mutilation of children
my I believe that to be wrong like I
believe it's actually a crime against
humanity the reason I believe that by
the way is the U.N definition of crime
against humanity one of them is
involuntary sterilization my sense is
that if you're a medical professional
and you sterilize a child that's
involuntary sterilization because they
are not qualified to give qualified
consent informed consent as anyone with
any sense recognizes yeah they can't
even go on a field trip without getting
uh signature right or you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah right so they can yeah
they can't go on like a yeah there are
there are hospitals now genital field
trips yeah well there there are
hospitals now when they inform the
children of what's going to happen for
example if they castrate them for
example
um they tell them the girls
um obviously they're not castrating the
girls they're just doing double
mastectomies and sterilizing the girls
but they tell them that they might have
to have their eggs stored because this
is going to interfere with their
fertilization and if they ever want to
have children well that'll be what
they'll have to do it's like well you
know every 12 year old is capable yeah
no kidding
sick it is absolutely despicable I
believe that the people who've done this
should be in prison for the rest of
their lives so do you think no excuse
speaking up against things like that are
some of the reasons why they're kind of
oh I think that was the primary reason
well I I tweeted something out about
Elliot page Ellen Page yeah remember
we're in trouble now we're already in
trouble trouble yeah I said that I said
do you remember when Pride was a sin and
when a criminal physician cut off Elliot
Allen Page's breasts and uh that got me
kicked off Twitter but that was also one
of the tweets that was complained about
you know and I had friends I actually
did a whole YouTube video on this uh I
had friends who kind of upgraded me for
being a little harsh and we talked it
over on YouTube for about 90 minutes and
I don't regret it at all in fact I think
that in the intervening year since that
tweet or so the tides turned very firmly
in a direction that indicates that my
suspicions were more than warranted do
you think like so so yeah I think what
I'm trying to think more about is just
like the challenge like about Free
Speech right like about how it's being
challenged everywhere it's going to be
really strange if those people get you
in front of a board they're not going to
do that oh I don't think they have a
choice actually I think what they'll try
to publish it you know they'll try to
keep it secret but that ain't gonna
happen they should you have to do
pay-per-view yeah no kidding no kidding
absolutely absolutely I know I know when
you want to be your corner man if
there's rounds I want to come in between
rounds well you were asking if I was
looking forward to it and like I said
um you have to be a fool to look forward
to legal proceedings but I went through
all 13 of the charges over Christmas
last last December you know which was
not a very pleasant three days because
you never know when you have hundreds of
pages of paperwork which I had to go
through you never know if you you never
know when you might have done something
stupid that's going to catch up with you
you know and everybody has stupidity in
their past and so I was pretty damn
apprehensive when I went through all the
paperwork but when the more I delved
into it actually the the better I felt
because not only did they make terrible
procedural errors like going ahead with
the complaints of people who literally
claimed falsely in writing to be clients
of mine and I think six of the
complaints are like that but it's just
so utterly preposterous I mean two of
the things they complain about are
literally criticisms of of Trudeau and
like if I can't criticize a standing
prime minister in my own country there
is something seriously wrong one of them
was his chief of staff one of them was a
city councilor
um one of them was the trans issue that
we discussed one of them I criticized uh
Sports Illustrated for presenting a very
obese cover model and I said that as far
as I was concerned she wasn't beautiful
and that no amount of tolerant of
authority carrying compassion was going
to convince me otherwise and they say
the process is the punishment right and
when you're facing this is what's
happened to me in Canada too it's like
I'm essentially facing an adversary that
has indefinite resources and time right
and so right they just hope to yeah they
can just grind you out they can grind me
down they could make it they could just
keep they're not going to though right
so they're not going to